Daisy will lead you to the monster once
the monster is in the arena deploy your
harpoon traps then start dealing damage
with the machine pistol keep an eye on
Daisy
the icon above her head will tell you if
she's tracking the monster Daisy can
detect sneaky monsters when Daisy is
sniffing the ground the monster is in
stealth mode nearby Daisy will lead you
in the right direction if Daisy isn't
tracking the monster lead her around the
map until she picks up the scent again
it won't take long
Daisy the lead you in the right
direction but you might need to break
away at the end to get in front of the
monster and traffic once you have the
monster trapped in the mobile arena hide
and defend yourself until backup arrives
if you go down so does the mobile arena
the monster can destroy harpoon traps
before they armed hide your traps in
spots where the monster is less likely
to destroy them once the traps are
placed lure the monster towards them
remember to plant some harpoon traps as
you enter combat as these will aid in
your team's escape should they need to
but keep in mind that traps take a few
moments to arm machine pistol is an
accurate but powerful shoot in firsts
and aim for weak spots in the monsters
armor to deal the most damage possible
plant your sound spikes as you move
through the environment choke points and
feeding grounds are often the best
locations once you have the monster
trapped in the mobile arena hide and
defend yourself until backup arrives if
you go down so does the mobile arena
after you deploy the mobile arena plant
a sound spike so your damage dealers can
locate the monster and close in for the
kill in combat keep the monster between
yourself and your teammates a
well-placed harpoon can stop a charging
monster dead in its tracks and save the
lives of your fellow hunters
wait until the monster notices the
harpoon cable then release the trigger
before he can break it this will start
the reload a fraction of a second sooner
by the time the monster has recovered
you should be ready to harpoon it again
your submachine gun should only be used
when a sound spike has been placed and
there's no need for a mark nor the
submachine gun deals the little damage
so aim for the monsters head or weak
points in its armor as you move through
the map use the tracker dart on as much
wildlife as possible paying particular
attention to easy prey like Marsh
Striders if the Monster eats these
creatures the tracker dart will
automatically trigger just before the
mobile arena goes down hit the monster
with a tracker Dart so that you can
follow it for as long as possible
once in combat keep the area covered in
stasis grenades this slows the monster
effectively neutralizing its melee
damage as well as making the monster a
slower moving target for teammates the
spread of the custom shotgun worsens as
you shoot faster slow down the pace and
pick your shots to improve accuracy and
damage
you